die wasserstraßen von venedig in
majestätischer ruhe ein äußerst seltener
anblick
die gondoliere kommen langsam zurück in
die kanäle der stadt aber noch sind die
fahrgäste rasen auf dem markusplatz wo
es normalerweise von touristen nur so
wimmelt laufen die geschäfte schleppend
mit der korona krise kam das leben in
der stadt regelrecht zum stillstand
nun öffnet sich venedig langsam wieder
für besucher aber nicht jeder freut sich
auf die rückkehr der massen jane dem
motto sie dies als eine möglichkeit die
zukunft zu verändern
die hacktivisten setzt sich für
nachhaltigen tourismus ein
einen der die zukunft der stadt nicht
aufs spiel setzt problem mit venedig ist
dass es ein extrem fragiles
empfindliches system ist man kann nicht
alles damit machen
man muss ja vorsichtig damit umgehen
sonst bleibt in zukunft nichts mehr
übrig von venedig wir müssen
verantwortlich mit dem vermächtnis von
venedig umgehen und daran denken was es
uns gegeben hat
andere menschen haben auch das recht das
zu bekommen erzählt uns venedig habe
einen einzigartigen lebensstil und der
droht zu verschwinden
da in dem motto möchte dass touristen
wieder am leben in der stadt teilnehmen
zeit in den restaurants und museen
verbringen und nicht in wenigen stunden
hindurch reihen
obwohl die letzten monate ohne gäste für
ihn sehr schwer waren stellt sich auch
nicolo bortolo für seine stadt eine
andere zukunft vor der hotelier möchte
seinen gästen einen entschleunigten br
sagt wirklich venezianisches erlebnis
bieten die touristenströme müsse man mit
strenger regulierung in den griff
bekommen
wenn an manchen tagen viel zu viele
menschen hier rumlaufen waren deshalb
weil die events in der stadt falsch
organisiert werden kann man die regatta
im canale grande zur gleichen zeit
austragen wie das filmfest oder die
neueröffnung eines museums ich denke wir
sollten den tourismus auf das ganze jahr
verteilen und nicht nur auf sechs monate
[Musik]
in der 61 venedig muss einen tourismus
neu definieren das findet auch die
tourismusbeauftragter der stadt
aber anstelle von drastischen maßnahmen
möchte sie lieber erstmal weiter fakten
sammeln
das ist kein museum
wir liegen keine obergrenze fest kennen
sie eine stadt in der welt die das macht
ja ich glaube nicht viele viele menschen
sprechen über die zahl der touristen ist
in 50 millionen 30 millionen usw
aber das ist nicht wahr ich will sie
zählen ich werde wissen wie viele
menschen jeden tag kommen
in europa werden die reisebeschränkungen
allmählich aufgehoben
viel zeit haben die venezianer also
nicht mehr um zu entscheiden wie die
zukunft ihrer stadt aussehen soll